Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Arrow the shit pretty much hit the fan.
All the characters started to connect the
dots on what’s really been happening all
year and we got a major teaser for season
3.
If you’re finding me for the first time
I do Arrow videos every week and to celebrate
the final I’ve been doing special bonus
videos and Q&As, be sure to subscribe to get
everything.
I’ll have links to all that stuff in the
description and at the end of the video.
So let’s start with Top 5 moments, and then
I’ll do my review.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it yet.
Here we go.
Number 5 - The New Arrow Cave
It may or may not be a teaser for them getting
a new Arrow Cave in season 3.
I wouldn’t be surprised.
Oliver’s other base of operations basically
has everything but the gear.
And because Felicity and Diggle didn’t know
about it, it means Slade and Isabel don’t
know about it.
Remember how I keep saying Team Arrow is growing,
when you look at shots like this where they’re
all hunched over Roy, it makes the current
Arrow Cave look claustrophobic.
It’s almost like there’s barely room to
do Salmon Ladders.
The new Arrow Cave looks a lot like Christian
Bale’s Dark Knight Batcave underneath the
construction site.
Just a nice wide open area to train and shoot
arrows at tennis balls.
Don’t be surprised if next year Oliver moves
them to the new space, given the addition
of Roy, Laurel and maybe even Thea.
Number 4 - Ravager Returns the Favor
I like that they modeled her costume after
the comic book Ravager instead of just giving
her the hockey mask everyone else is wearing.
I always love watching Summer Glau fight,
so I’m hoping that Nyssa Al Ghul and Sara
will take her on in the finale.
In case you were wondering, the first official
picture from the finale was of Nyssa.
Isabel’s major arc is essentially over,
she’s accomplished her goal of taking over
Queen Industries.
All she’s doing now is pouring salt in the
wound and taking Revenge on Diggle for killing
her.
The plus side of that being, that most of
her time in the last two episodes is going
to be spent dancing around with swords.
Just sit back and enjoy the show.
It reminds me of Serenity when she killed
all the Reavers with those blades.
Number 3 - Felicity Will Be Your Interrogator
Can we please have more Felicity double take
moments like this next season?
I love how her humor worked with the larger
Brother Blood Army storyline.
Even when the shit hits the fan she finds
time to slip a few jokes in.
I love how she uses her skills to get the
information out of him, instead of Diggle
beating him to death.
It’s like that “Pen Is Mightier than the
Sword” scene from Indiana Jones.
In this case it was Felicity is mightier than
the fist.
I can’t wait to see the Bitch with Wifi
tumblr gifs.
If you didn’t catch it later, when she was
in the van Cisco Ramon was calling her about
the cure.
Number 2 - Laurel In The Arrow Cave
This was huge and totally unexpected.
I knew she’d be helping them but I thought
it would be under the radar until the finale
or even season 3.
But I loved that she was his call to action.
And that they remembered Tommy.
Based on these new developments I would plan
on Laurel acting as the new Quentin if he
were a real member of the team.
She might even end up running for Mayor if
they don’t do the Oliver Queen Mayor story
from the comic books.
I know everyone keeps asking about her becoming
the Black Canary and Sara’s status during
the finale is still unkown, but I still feel
like it’s too soon for Laurel to go all
parkour and black leather.
Number 1 - Team Arrow Tries to Convince Oliver
Not To Commit Suicide
The best Arrow scenes are always the team
scenes.
Especially when they get so emotional Felicity
starts to cry.
It reminded me a lot of that scene in episode
13 at the campaign rally where Felicity got
so upset when she thought she might lose Oliver.
After all they’ve been through they’re
as much a family as you can be.
I think this was the last type of scene like
this we’ll see until the finale.
It was that moment of silence between Moira’s
Death and the Army being released.
But now that they’re out, the next episode
is going to be all explosions.
But now it’s your turn, let me know what
your favorite moments was.
Felicity with wifi, Laurel in the Arrow Cave
or the mirakuru army?
Here’s a couple bonus moments that were
really important but didn’t make my top
5 -
Oliver revealing himself to Brother Blood.
He was basically trying to reason with him.
Blood really is Slade’s pawn.
I keep saying that he’ll get thrown under
the bus before the end.
I did like that Blood had a real plan for
Starling City.
It reminded me of when Merlyn talked about
his plan for Starling in Season 1, save it
by destroying it.
Then there was the Thea plot.
She’s going to run into Merlyn next week.
We even saw him in the teaser.
It sounds like she’s slowly connecting the
dots between Slade and Oliver and the Island.
And because we saw Merlyn in his Dark Archer
gear I think Thea will definitely learn the
truth about everything.
Meaning she’ll either go away with Merlyn
or join Team Arrow in season 3.
Felicity’s call at the end was also really
important.
That was Cisco calling her about the Mirakuru
Cure.
Because the soldiers are scattered all over
the city, the cure is going to probably have
to be airborne.
Or maybe a bomb.
Whatever it is, it will be really cool.
And Slade calling Brother Blood pretending
to be his father.
I just thought that was really funny given
all the talking he did about his parents at
Moira’s wake.
Overall I gave the episode an A minus, just
because there was no way they were going to
top the end of last week’s episode.
I can’t say enough about the character development
this season.
I’m mostly talking about Laurel, but even
the core team members have changed in really
profound ways and will continue to until the
finale.
Felicity even kind of shone a light on it
when she told Oliver you’ve been trying
really hard this season not to kill people.
But there were another couple lines of dialogue
that I think foreshadowed the finale.
The biggest was Isabel Rochev mentioning the
Island.
If you saw my predictions I said they’ll
probably end the season back on the Island.
Then Felicity geeking out on Amanda Waller’s
gear.
It was adorable, but I think she’s going
to get her hands on some of it for season
3.
Kind of tying in with my idea that they’ll
get a whole new upgraded Arrow Cave.
So let me know what you’re hoping to see
next week.
It’s basically going to be the mirakuru
army punishing the city and Oliver trying
to drop the cure bomb on them.
Be sure to subscribe to get my video, and
leave me suggestions for next week’s bonus
video.
My Q&A will post tomorrow like normal.
You can click here to get it.
I’ll add the annotation as soon as I post
it and click here for my breakdown of the
Justice League movie.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!